la légende raconte qu'ils sont nés dans
les murs de cette abbaye il y à plus de
mille ans les macarons de cormery
quelques centimètres de pâte sucrée en
forme d'anneau qui font la renommée en
touraine de ce petit village et dans la
rue quand vous demandez aux passants
s'ils connaissent cette gourmandise
la réponse est immédiate pâtisserie là
c'est les macarons de cormeray le
macaron classique c'est celui qui est
toutes les couleurs à base de pâte
d'amande l'aï si vous avez un macaron
qui est plutôt sablé avec un petit goût
de nougat derrière qui revient surtout
un goût de tous c'est ça l'essentiel
dans le village deux boulangeries
fabrique la célèbre pâtisserie selon une
recette ancestrale suivi scrupuleusement
par pascal de beaux pâtissier ici on a
deux sortes de potsdam en une pâte
d'amande blanche une poudre d'amande
grise là on a donc un succès boule et la
du miel les ingrédients sont ensuite
mélangées avant de former une pâte
donc là on regarde la texture et le
textures et bomal souple ça se transmet
de génération en génération et de
propriétaires en propriétaire le macaron
en le en lui-même date de 971 donc c'est
vraiment une recette qui est très très
vieille aujourd'hui pascal de beaux
fabrique près de 2000 macarons par
semaine et les exporte même jusqu'au
japon où il a été présenté en personne
le désormais célèbre petit biscuit le
japonais sont très très friands de ce
prologue
ils sont très friandes historique et ils
sont très friands du macaron c'est un
matin il me fait voyager alors je suis
très très fier faire découvrir le
macaron et peut-être aussi attirer les
touristes
c'est le pari de la commune le
réfectoire en fait c'est toute la partie
qui va du renfort la dont l'ancienne
abbaye où aurait été inventé la
pâtisserie la mairie espère se servir du
macaron pour créer un vrai circuit
touristique remettre en état le bâtiment
historique
l'objectif que l'on a c'est d'arriver à
valoriser ce site qui était un peu
délaissé sur les années sur les quelques
dizaines d'années passées et donc le
macaron de cormery c'est une opportunité
de se faire connaître et attirer
également du touriste à cormery des
touristes qui pourront peut-être bientôt
visiter l'abbaye millénaire et déguster
le plus ancien macarons de france